now I know we're in the technology age
but I don't want you to forget about
offline groups and events they're great
ways to expand your user base and to
improve your branding or if you do it
right generate some PR as for industry
events you can have a booth at a
relevant conference you could be active
in meetups you can even host relevant
events now if you have the resources
hosting events is a great thing for a
few different reasons one it can help
you attract talent to join your team or
can help you find writers to feature you
in an article if you're a business to
business or b2b company hosting events
in a topic that attracts your potential
customers is also a great way to gain
users